فوائد جمه من تدريب كبار السن على اجهزه
الكمبيوتر واستخدام مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي المختلفه بحسب الدراسات الحديثه
فالانترنت يمكن ان يربطهم بشكل ايجابي
بالاخرين ويساعدهم على تعلم معلومات او
مهارات جديده من خلال منصات وتطبيقات
اجتماعيه جديده ويمكن ان يؤدي استخدام
كبار السن لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا
الى توثيق ارتباطهم بالاخرين وتقليل
اسلتهم فاظهرت الدراسات ان كبار السن
الذين يعانون من الوحده كانوا اكثر عرضه
للاصابه بالخرف بثلاث مرات من اولئك الذين
قالوا انهم شعروا بارتباط اجتماعي مع
الاخرين
وتوصل الباحثون الى ان الذين استخدموا
الانترنت بشكل متكلم مره واحده في اليوم
او اكثر كانت لديهم مستويات اقل بكثير من
اعراض الاكتئاب وابلغوا عن جوده حياه اعلى
مقارنه باولئك الذين استخدموا الانترنت
مره واحده فقط في الاسبوع او اقل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات